Alex an accident yesterday who hit the
white pieces but immediately bounced
back and you started off with this G6 at
move one how did you come up with this
idea Yasser said that he he would have
lost a lot of money if he was going to
bet on your opening Choice uh no I'm
surprised yeah uh yes sir uh would say
that because
my coach yeah and Elvis for this
tournament and for previous one as well
uh just published a book on gurgaonida's
system early this year and I was right
in the forward for it and the book was
based on our preparation to
2017 that was the last year's
championship that I was playing in and I
played a couple of games
and with gurganida in that tournament
and uh one of them again against uh Ray
Robinson uh is still I think of the
world it's a top theory in the morning
so uh
uh we felt that the moment came to
advertise a book a little bit
that's a good advertisement
and I was saying that I mean your
opening Choice was definitely successful
and at this point he decided to go
completely berserk uh I I would say that
all those years that Patrick did not
play competitive chess you know uh and
he was the one that was making things
happening in this game yeah I was just I
was ready for you know Bishop comes back
H5 F4 I will go before take on C3 you
know and we saw you on the camera you
came back from the restroom and probably
you spotted the bishop on H6 as you were
coming along what was your initial
reaction to this bishop takes H6 there
are other shock obviously
um yeah I was first I was thinking that
I blunder something in case something
very direct but then I realized that
Patrick just wants uh to do a slow
attack with G5 and H5 and but with all
this uh counter sacrifices on the E5 I
felt that should be at least I should
not lose directly so you're you're quite
comfortable uh yeah when I took you know
I realized that I got through K8
um yeah Knight F4 if you need to play
Knight F4 then it's probably a little
too slow but uh apparently positions
still very interesting very sharp and I
felt like uh my conversion was not the
best yeah I would say you handled it
quite well
um I don't think you ever relinquished
your advantage after this
yep no it was all clean yeah but
somewhere over here maybe here yes
somewhere over here uh takes takes
I wasn't sure maybe Rook H1 maybe a rook
H1 uh what did I do
um he didn't play Rook H1 right but I
have to go
oh no Rook H1 I can go King J it right
yes
that's about the same F4
so now it goes oh oh now it doesn't go
anywhere because Bishop takes it I see
but then Queen takes a knight cannot
move again you can not have seven and
then we get this position this imbalance
it seems a little bit dicey but probably
black is still slightly better
okay yeah I cannot take on D4 yeah that
that was unclear but Patrick was already
in time travel and he played this move
A3
after that they managed to yeah A3 was
too slow more or less cement your
advantage
um trade very nice congratulations thank
you Alex important victory for you who
do you see as your main competitor well
uh no obviously the two main competitors
uh
were squared off today and
Vladimir Gregory yeah so I still think
those two guys will be uh very much in
the mix uh no of course Malik is having
the greatest greatest tournament so far
even though he won couple of uh
yeah
uh but yeah so I would say those three
names so far
Vladimir Malik and Gregory yes sir any
questions yeah well first of all
congratulations on the book with
gergenness I didn't know the gurgaonitza
system sorry I didn't know that you were
working on that book otherwise I
wouldn't have made the BET
second of all I love the way you came in
and said I've been working with my coach
we asked the junior players you know
who's your coach who are you working
with what are your Ambitions we don't
ask the seniors who's your coach who
you're working with what's your ambition
yes I'm in uh uh Jan Ellis was invited
to this tournament and he in my opinion
he should have come but
he decided that he cannot some family
obligation that he can fulfill and but
I'll still to see him playing here in
the years to come so he's not here with
you he's not no he's not here with you
training he's not here with me not not
in Saint Louis now
well uh nice recovery from yesterday's
loss and coming back with black pieces I
mean congratulations I have one question
about the game and that is you mentioned
that Knight F4 maybe it's not the best
move to play for white what if white
plays F4 what was your idea there F4 yes
do you like uh
Catherine you're right I mean position
was absolutely uh yeah I I felt that
white should have proceed slowly and F4
probably was the move to go yeah Knight
F4 again I attributed to Patrick's uh
you know I haven't been played chess for
a long time and he tried to force
matters but uh yeah F4 looked like a
very interesting uh positional way to
continue I I would I totally uh
assess the position is unclear
well congratulations uh Alex and good
luck uh with the tournament thank you
absolutely as 4